so like they'll put like a turtle Maze
of all white shoes
and then they'll have a black shirt
racist turtle and the turtle will just
walk the maze but when he sees the black
one and I'll Attack it well it makes
sense because Turtles are like 300 years
old so they're living in another time
yeah did you see the one
[Music]
all right so this one is very close to
my heart it uh made me pretty upset
so listen to this you guys know the
whole thing with catalytic converters
right yeah they're getting stolen like
crazy stolen in the hole I did not know
that it was to this degree in the past
five years the theft is up in California
728 percent
yeah purse because there was already a
lot being stolen it's a good side hustle
wow so they they uh California failed
experiment
not yet starting to feel like it okay
yeah it's um I mean if you live in
Pasadena you probably can't feel it
right
that's how you feel it I mean you got
homeless people arguing outside of your
front you already said yeah but you know
what it's gone down
yeah but it went down because of you no
you know what the problem is why I think
a lot of people in California have a
problem we've all been in such crazy
Stockholm Syndrome
that when we're here like oh at least my
boyfriend's not beating me anymore and
they're like everything is good but then
you go to every other state and you're
like oh no it's actually a lot more work
to do still uh yeah yeah well it's like
oh wow my Governor doesn't hate me it's
kind of crazy like all right they hate
the governor hates you if you live in a
gated community you're insulated from
all that [__]
and you forget about all the stuff that
you saw on the way to your house here
here I have a friend that lives in a
gator community in the OC you know him
too
um eight figure house car just gets
taken from the driveway and gonzos so
people are following people home and the
crime is crazy yeah lock the gate so the
um California filed a motion to ban
owning a catalytic converter that's not
yours like you just can't have them no
shut the [__] no [__] [__] dude right
but what about all the shops that
so brilliant well because if you're like
a Reit yeah how many of your government
is really smart they don't sell
catalytic converters they sell cars that
have them but nobody's selling them oh
you see that new law hey we gotta return
a message
get all of them together so aren't they
just tempting poor people having by
letting you own a catalytic converter
you're you're basically tempting poor
people you're putting a jewel in the
window yeah that's that's essentially
the I mean they rip them up and strip
them for their copper and all that stuff
in resell right or like scrap yeah so
like maybe they should probably look at
all the places that are taking the scrap
metal at on the parts of Cadillac well
they're the criminal they're the
criminals too yeah and they do get
because it's such a problem they sell
locks for it now like they know the
parts where they they got Shields yeah
so that you can buy like almost like the
club for the steering wheel they have it
for your catalytic converter because
it's such a problem
I saw a California congresswoman argue
that
um it's the car company's fault that's
this article okay okay yeah so it's the
car company's fault because you should
be able they should house them better so
that they're not exposed so that they
can't be stolen well the first the the
thing is California requires a catalytic
converter yeah because other states
don't require that right we got those
because of our smog laws and then that
councilwoman said nothing about that but
here's the thing in that motion to ban
unlawful possession of catalytic
converters it was passed but it was past
eight to four so four of the council
people did not believe that this is the
right decision they asked nithya Rahman
who's the one you're talking about they
asked her why did you vote against it
here's something she said and it's just
like I cannot believe this is our
Council passing the book making this
illegal will negatively impact Black and
Latino communities that's racist
[Laughter]
you know you know okay so so so so so so
so so so so
if the if the largest victims are the
poor communities in California which
tends to be immigrant communities
they're getting hit the worst with these
catalytic converter crimes in her mind
she's thinking the culprits are black in
Mexicans and you're like you can't take
away their [__] racket
she's what yeah that's don't say don't
say that whities can't be meth heads
dude yeah whiteys want the copper too
there are yeah
okay assuming that most of the culprits
are black and Mexican but most of the
victims is the Immigrant poor
communities and they're getting their
cars ripped off in Catalan they're not
steel they're not going to Beverly Hills
to steal that [__] they can't go into
Beverly Hills garages and still is nope
exactly there are a lot of um yeah she's
right there are a lot of uh low-income
neighborhood people that are doing this
crime some of them are are Vietnamese
and Asian too like there's some like
huge rings that span across the country
that are Asian but they target mostly
low-income communities but when they say
this [__] too right
that's like you know that's like the
racism of saying like well nobody who
lives in Beverly Hills is even a race at
all it's just white he's there which is
racist too yeah yeah like Michael Jordan
doesn't live there right
it's all uh it's also but the reason why
I think the um negatively in fact the
impact in his communities is because
um she's trying to be against punishment
as a whole for these people and because
that'll put them in jail for being the
ones that are doing this crime so
another thing she said is the thing you
said where she says if Toyota makes a
car part that's the same value as a
Macbook they shouldn't have made it so
easy to steal they don't have the state
require it thank you she never said she
never addresses hey do something about
how math books are expensive too thanks
yeah yeah Jesus Christ bring the prices
yeah one of macbook's so stealable that
you just take it off the desk like it's
nothing MacBooks are easy to steal too
thank you exactly
uh and also she says the city
there's no resale market for MacBooks
like that
you gotta strip them apart yeah yeah she
says that the uh that it should be the
city's responsibility to make a victim
of theft hole instead of punishing
another person so let the let let the
let the thievery go on but then let's
ensure the people that got jacked but is
it the city our money that we pay in tax
anyways
a hundred percent so that's not fair to
be we're paying them to [__] enforce
the law yeah right one of the craziest
laws I heard that's our bills that's
trying to get past uh from our from my
friend that's a cop is they want to ban
police dogs
because police dogs uh
disproportionately bite black and brown
and so I guess they're making it a race
issue versus a low income or like type
issue so like if they take that tool
away which is one of their best tools
it's like how the [__] are they gonna do
any policing
and that's really strange because I
thought dogs aren't inherently racist
they are they are and the eyes of these
types of people that's right hey I've
watched like a trainer that's racist
I've watched a lot of episodes of Cops
and those dogs bite the hell out of some
white dudes
sometimes those those dogs bite the cops
too yeah
I've seen footage of like cops like
trying to arrest this guy and then the
dog's like pulling on the cop's leg oh
dude that was I saw that one but have
you guys seen the turtle that only bites
and attacks the black shoes no you never
see this so like they'll put like a
turtle Maze of all white shoes
and the turtle will just walk the maze
when he sees the black one and I'll
Attack it well it makes sense because
Turtles are like 300 years old so
they're living in another time yeah did
you see the one
that's funny
I saw one of a turtle only biting and
attacking the Viet shoes really that
Turtle must be my grandfather bro
this is my grandfather he looked like a
turtle
yeah but that's this thing just Heats me
up because it's like first of all like
you said California requires us to all
have it which is what makes it a problem
when we get our stolen is you can't be
riding around without it otherwise you
would just pipe the area where it's gone
and just not have one but then you get a
fine print if they gave a [__] about
disaffected communities and poor people
they would get rid of stupid ass street
sweeping which is dude attack thank you
attack thank you they don't care about
poor people they don't give a [__] they
can't wait to tax for people but pretend
like they're doing it for some
environmental reasons yeah parking laws
in lower income roads are way the
[__] because they're so [__]
confusing and also poor people tend to
not compete against the law so like
there's less Karen's there's more
immigrants they can't yeah they don't
have lawyers they don't know how to do
it so if it's like for some reason all
those parking laws and tickets and those
snitch tickets which are uh proven to be
really [__] predatory right which is
which is those red lines
unconstitutional yeah it has to be
observed by a police officer but most of
those are in low-income neighborhoods
most of them are yeah you go to court go
talk to people who are there I've been
to court bro I had to do jury duty down
there I was talking to people people are
sick of this kind of [__] and nobody's
sticking up for them there's not a
politician that is even exists for them
yeah and we all know it and then stupid
Council women like this or councilmen
like this they stand up for some issue
and everyone's just confused about it
and everyone's like what the [__] are
you talking about in the meantime and
there's real issues that people want a
dress that never do get addressed and I
think it's probably because of the upper
middle class snobby uh white guilt
people that are like oh we can't blame
the criminals we can't treat them this
way but it's like now you're unleashing
them onto the poor communities and it
makes it worse on them yeah because
they're not going to the Palisades they
get right when they get released it's
not it's not in these gated communities
they can't wait to release them and feel
good about themselves the parking thing
is crazy because that's always in areas
where the population's so dense yep that
it's a tricky thing to even get
everybody seven blocks away you can't
wake up early enough to get there before
street sweeping at 6am or whatever what
day is it again on what side of the
street yeah such a joke one day my buddy
he uh he was staying at his girlfriend's
house and his girlfriend in Pasadena
lives in like a very nice area
and he left his car there overnight
and usually you get a ticket if you
don't go by a permit right right he
wakes up in the morning and he sees a
ticket on his debt on his uh on his
window and he's like ah [__] I got a
ticket he looks at it and the ticket is
this is a warning
for a parking ticket
and then your head you go like how would
you know next time but it's just like
okay the fact that they even do that you
don't get that you don't get that in
Koreatown yeah I'll tell you that I live
there they do this in these really nice
areas where I'm like why do they do a
warning ticket it's either you did it or
you didn't do it right like either you
have the permit or you don't I've seen
nice people who had no money at all and
they're crying talking to one of these
parking attendants because they missed
it by 30 seconds and they're standing
like can I move my car right now can you
not give me the ticket right now I'm
like no I have to already started it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which is the
worst thing but then yeah you get a
warning if you live in the rich area
yeah but so it's like the corruption is
on on dude that's that's I got a really
really good view of that when I was
living in between Hollywood and then
half the time in Lincoln Heights when
I'm in Lincoln Heights like we had a
problem with uh this homeless population
there was like a basically a chop shop
that had opened up on the street where
they were just like dismantling bikes
and motorcycles and cars all day and
they had been being complained about for
so much and the city couldn't do
anything about it so what the city did
was the city appointed a security guy
for the complex I lived at so that those
people couldn't come in but they
wouldn't fix the actual problems over in
Hollywood by the way in this area that's
uh called Fairfax Hills there's a
freaking dedicated police officer who is
the police officer for the region and
anytime there's any complaint that cop
will come and just to make sure
everyone's okay so the difference is
that those police there are there for
you the citizen to make sure you're all
right over there it doesn't work that
way it's the opposite yeah they're like
hey that's that's what the world is
sorry yeah yeah over there it's like
they're basically like uh concierge yeah
so you can't help but to throw your
hands up yeah like I'll get a visit from
the district hop and he's like hey is
everything cool I saw like there was
some construction in front of your house
everything's all right like no one's
jamming up the street like what that's
true because the cops in the city
government if you're in a rich
neighborhood it feels like they work for
you yeah and then when you're in a poor
neighborhood it feels like they control
you they want to keep the the people the
residents of those houses happy so that
they don't leave so everything's cool
right but then in a rich neighborhood a
lot of these people have power like they
have connections they're tied to the
government they got money for lawyers
they could make the lives of the city
workers so miserable that they don't
want to deal with them if you're in a
poor Community that's a whole different
story call the cops in Beverly Hills
what's the average response time call
the cops in Koreatown call the cops
somewhere else right good luck right 25
minutes what response exactly
exactly but then they're told hey don't
don't hold don't own guns though right
don't own guns don't do that if you're
low if you're low income like I had a
buddy he lives in like [__] Marina
Del Rey and he's like why does anyone
need a gun I don't [__] get it and I
mean he was Marina Del Rey dude that's
why that's why you think you don't need
a gun you want if I lived in Marina del
Rey I wouldn't want a gun either yeah
because why do I need one because you
call the [__] cops and they're there
in 35 seconds are you kidding me I don't
need a gun because you know I live in a
gated community in the Securities out
front already have guns exactly yeah the
people yeah that's funny exactly yeah
meanwhile the people getting shot up all
the time are all the same low income
people nobody gives a [__] about them
though it sucks too when you hear a
politician like all nithya Rahman seems
like she's doing is trying to steer it
towards the thing she's fighting for
which is lower incarceration for people
of color okay cool that's your
initiative fine but don't shoehorn that
into a catalytic converter situation
dude that's so different right ass
backwards I'm like you can still fight
for that and also fight for people not
being victims of theft because now we
think you're not very logical in how you
make these arguments I think they're
dumb as [__] who are the victims of
the theft of the catalytic converters
some people that can't afford to fix it
who are the victims of people that don't
go to jail they stay in the communities
that they're basically terrorizing yeah
so everyone at home just take out your
your catalytic converter now just take
it out and sell it you'll be okay well
but if you live in California you have
to have one though so just hold on to it
okay so just make it easier for them
take your MacBook and then put it under
the catalog let's take the MacBook
instead
turn your location services on by the
way it's also just as a little added
thing it's illegal to put a trap for
someone trying to steal your catalytic
converter what the [__] the [__]
California how much are they again you
can't even put a barbed wire around it
you can't do anything that might if that
guy gets hurt it's on you oh my god hey
that's your state Nick
it wasn't as bad as it was before
hey don't make fun of me dude
[Music]